hi my name is Chad McArthur I'm an RIT
scientist here at Thermo Fisher
Scientific thanks for joining us 24
hours of stem cells today I'm going to
be showing you how to use EDTA to
passage your pluripotent stem cells
cultured in essential 8 medium so EDTA
is a is a non enzymatic gentle way to
passage your cells and EDTA works by
chelating divalent cations and this
disrupts the function of cell adhesion
molecules allowing you to harvest your
cells so why don't we take a look at
what we'll need to get started so what
we need is the cells that we're going to
passage which I've got right here and we
also need our plate that the cells are
going to be passage into so this should
be pre coated with the the matrix of
your choosing in this case we're going
to be using vit Renekton but other
choices include jell tricks or laminin
521 what we also need is D PBS without
calcium and magnesium and that's to wash
our cells we also need a point 5
millivolts Ellucian of EDTA and that
should be made up using this same d PBS
without calcium and magnesium and last
we need essentially a medium which has
been pre warm to room temperature
remember it's best to not warm up edie
essentially in the water bath or the
incubator we want to just leave it out
at room temperature for 30 to 60 minutes
to let it to let it warm up so once we
have everything that we need why don't
we take a look at the cells and so
ideally you want your cells to be about
70 to 80 percent confluent when they're
ready to pass it you don't want your
cells to to be a hundred percent
confluent so I'll show you a few
different example densities so this this
is the one I'm gonna passage today it
looks it looks pretty good you know you
want to still be able to see some spaces
between between the colonies like I said
you don't want to complete my
lair and so this looks about what we
want for example of under confluent
here's some cells that were plated at a
little bit lower density and you can see
there's still plenty of room to grow so
for this one I would wait at least
another day until until you want to go
ahead and pass that one and for another
example here's cells that are completely
overgrown and a hundred percent
confluent you can see there's there is
no space in between any of the colonies
maybe a little bit here and there but
pretty much 100% confluent so this is
what you want to avoid you know these
cells should have been passage to
yesterday or possibly the day before
that if you do find that your cells are
hundred percent confluent it may it may
take longer to incubate the cells in
EDTA to really get them off and you may
find that the the recovery the next day
is a little bit lower than normal so
another thing you want to check once
you've verified how how dense the cells
are is is you want to verify their
morphology right you want to you want to
make sure that they're maintaining
pluripotency so so basically you want to
look for any differentiated areas any
dark spots any any cells that look like
they're differentiating but I'm seeing
mostly the hallmarks of quarry potent
cell morphology here you know nice
defined boundaries and a nice tight
compact cells within the colonies if you
do find any areas of differentiation you
do have the option of going in there and
cleaning it out you know assuming you
have a microscope in the hood like this
but you can take a p200 and kind of go
in there you know I can't really find
any differentiated areas in this culture
but if there was you just kind of go in
there and scratch it out
so once you've confirmed that your cells
are ready to passage and that you don't
see any areas of differentiation or that
you've cleaned those areas up we're
ready to start the protocol so the first
thing we want to do is wash the cells
twice with D PBS and this will get rid
of any residual calcium or magnesium
because if that's still there that will
interfere with EDTA working on your
cells to to allow dissociation so we're
gonna wash twice with D PBS so first
we're going to aspirate the media
and then we're going to add about two or
three mils of D PBS
and try to add it gently so we don't
disrupt ourselves so we just add that
you don't really have to let it sit on
there for very long and you're gonna
aspirate and add two more mils of VP vs
yeah yeah I've gotten
got a slow aspirator today
it's
there we go all right so we'll add one
more wash
[Applause]
and I do highly recommend you watch
twice you're really going to see better
results if you don't watch twice it's
probably been probably going to be a lot
harder to get your cells off the plate
[Applause]
all right
well I'll see how this works
all right aspirate that that's better
and now we're gonna add our EDTA
solution so I usually add one mill for
each well of a six well plate
[Applause]
[Applause]
at our one mill of 0.5 millimolar EDTA
[Applause]
we'll start the timer and so I'm going
to incubate this at 37
[Applause]
so you do have the option of incubating
either at room temperature which will
typically take about five to seven
minutes or you can incubate in the
incubator at 37 and that usually takes
about three to four minutes
no no real difference it just depends on
your preference I like 37 because it's
faster but you know if you want to do
room temperature that's perfectly fine
it's just going to take a little bit
longer so while we're waiting we can
talk about split ratios so nort you know
you there's a wide range of split ratios
that you may want to use depending on
your cell type and the matrix that those
cells would be called are being cultured
on and it's somewhat empirical you kind
of got to just play around and figure
out the optimal density for you we
usually say to start somewhere between
one to four and one to eight and then
kind of go from there especially if
you're working with a new cell line you
may want to initially try to play a few
different densities you know one two
four one two six one two eight one two
twelve something like that and then see
which one works best for you we usually
stick with about 1 to 6 and we culture
our cell cells every 3 to 4 days and
that seems to work well for us but but
yeah like I said you will see some
variations depending on the cell type
and and what matrix those cells are
being coded on are being cultured on
also as far as incubation time goes like
I said I normally just stick with 4
minutes at 37 but you may find again
that that you need to kind of play
around with that so basically when you
go to when you go to harvest your cells
you know if they come off way too easily
like you barely even have to to look at
them and they come off the plate then
then you've probably incubate it too
long and you want to next time shorten
your incubation time on the on the other
side if you if you go and you try to
harvest your cells and you're trying
really hard and you're pipetting and
they just won't come off the plate that
means you probably should incubate for
longer next time so you know again you
might just have to kind of play around
and see which which which one works best
for you but I think 4 minutes at 37 or 7
minutes at room temperature is a good
starting place and you kind of you can
adjust from there
so while we're waiting another thing we
should do is get our plate ready so so
like I said I have a six we'll play here
it's been pre coated with it Renekton so
I typically coat for about 60 minutes at
37 and so that's already been coated so
what we want to do is we're going to
aspirate the bit Renekton solution and
and then we're going to add essentially
media in there just going to add a
little bit so the wells don't dry out so
we'll aspirate the coating solution and
you don't really need to wash afterwards
it's not necessary so we're just going
to aspirate this
and then like I said we're going to add
just one mil of essentially just so the
plate doesn't dry out 1 mil to each Bowl
and so typically in a six-mile plate you
want a total volume of about two MLS so
since we have one in here then when a
time comes time to add ourselves we want
to add ourselves at about one mil per
well and so since I said a one to six
point ratio is probably ideal here we'll
collect ourselves in a total volume of
six mils and put one mil into each well
and then I'll give us a one to six
all right so we're coming up on four
minutes why don't we take a look
[Applause]
and so you can see the cells definitely
look different right I mean here's a
well that wasn't treated and here's well
that has been treated what you'll notice
is just a lot of kind of white space
coming up between the cells within the
colonies you can see which means that
they're they're dissociating now it's
hard to know you know you can't
necessarily look at it and know okay
it's ready
I still say just go with the times I
recommended but you can at least look at
this and say okay well udta is doing
something and hopefully they're gonna
come off so we want to aspirate the EDTA
solution now as I said hopefully your
cells aren't already floating when you
aspirate the EDTA solution if they are
you've incubated too long go shorter
next time but so my cell it didn't come
off there so that's good
so now we're going to add three mils of
essentially medium to lift the cells up
and so they should come off relatively
easily and what we want to do is we just
hold the plate at an angle and kind of
just dispense the media across the
surface of the well and hopefully as we
do that the cells come off pretty easily
and they are so you know if you have to
pipette a lot to get the cells off you
probably should have incubated a little
bit longer and so we want to keep our
pipetting down to a minimum okay I just
realized I did not prepare well all
right I need a tube to put these cells
into which I did not have so bear with
me all right
all right
sorry about that
so normally you would have a tube in the
hood ready to go so as I said we're
gonna take the cells put them into that
tube that was already in your hip and
then we're gonna wash the well out one
time with three more mils of EDTA
I'm sorry essentially medium so three
more mils so collect any leftover cells
and so as you're collecting the cells
you want to avoid pipetting up and down
too many times you know every time you
pipette up and down you're breaking the
cells up into smaller clumps and you
don't want those bumps to be too small
all right so we're gonna add this to
ourselves
and then we're just going to go up and
down a couple times we just want to kind
of evenly resuspend the cells and break
up any large clumps again over pipe
heading here you want to avoid because
that can that can lead to clumps that
are too small and if the pumps are too
small the cells just well you won't have
very good recovery so as I said six mils
one to six splits so we're gonna add one
mil to each well
[Applause]
all right
so and as soon as you're done adding the
cells you want to make sure to give it a
little shake cells passage this way you
know as soon as you start adding the
media back the EDTA the effects of EDTA
are reversed so the cells will stick to
the plate pretty quickly after you after
you add them so you want to make sure
you give it a little shake to spread the
cells out as soon as you can so I'm
going to return this to the incubator
[Applause]
and when you put it in I would give it
one more little shake just to make sure
the cells haven't pooled in the middle
and that's pretty much it I'll put this
one back too since we're done with that
and that one but it's that simple
[Applause]
okay and we're all done
so since we're all done I think we're
gonna take some questions from the
audience all right thank you very much
for that demonstration Chad definitely
great guidance for such a routine and
critical part of the report and stem
cell workflow some of our participants
do have questions to further dig in or
just for clarifications as such we will
now begin our Q&A session
I am Joanne aspart and like Chad I work
on thermo Fisher stem-cell products I
will be moderating this Q&A session
participants if you haven't yet please
type and send in your questions in the
mean time we do have a number of
questions already so I'll do this one
first because it's connected to
something you showed or explained
earlier but maybe just for clarification
and additional information is it
advisable to extend the duration of EDTA
treatment if the cells don't come off
but I think more to that point is there
such a thing as too long where you think
there's something wrong here and this
adding extra EDTA help good questions
I'll answer the second question first
I don't think adding extra EDTA really
does anything you could in theory up the
concentration but then you risk over
treatment so at the concentration we're
talking about 0.5 millimolar I think
there is a relatively large window you'd
probably have to leave it on there for
quite a while in most cases to really
over treat them just keep in mind you
know the longer it's on there the easier
it is it's gonna be to break up those
clumps right so if it is on there for a
really long time you just want to be
very gentle with your pipetting and not
and not over over pipette them to break
them up too small so I mean that's
pretty much the risk you run is just
that the longer you treat them the more
you treat them the the easier it is
gonna be to break up those clumps and if
the clumps are too small they're just
not going to attach well and they're not
gonna they're not going to grow very
well afterwards
and if you if you go and you find that
the cells are really just not coming off
at all you know once you add the ad in
the media it's it's it's too late to do
anything there but what you can do is I
mean if they're really just not coming
off you can aspirate the media and I
guess you would have to watch them a
couple more times with PBS and then add
a EDTA again and treat for another you
know four minutes and see if they come
off I don't it may work but you know and
just keep that in mind for Annette the
next time around you want to make sure
to treat them for longer and how many
cells should a clump have in average a
good question yeah that that's you know
it's it's hard to look at the clumps and
say hey that's a the 10 cell clump
that's a hundreds of clump but I would
say yeah probably in the neighborhood of
about a hundred to 500 cells per clump
is is good but this is a very you know
rough estimate because like I said
you're gonna have a hard time looking at
a clump and knowing exactly how many
cells are in there sure um this is
slightly different kind of question not
strictly within the realm of passages
but sort of related
do you count the cells before freezing
or for any other reason if yes what
method do you use a good question
we don't normally count the cells simply
because you know you have to keep PSCs
as clumps and so to count them you would
have to you know make them single cells
if you absolutely need a cell count what
you can do is take a small a lot of your
cells that are in clumps further
dissociate that to single cells with
something like trypsin or triple count
that and then kind of you know
extrapolate backwards to see how many
cells you have but I mean we find that
unless you have a really good reason
that you need to know the absolute cell
number there's no reason to do that you
work more on split ratios right like I
was saying 1 to 6 split 1 to 8
but when you go to freeze the cells down
you'll kind of just have a sense of how
good your freezing method is right I
think we normally take let's say one one
six well Camille probably two to three
vials that would then be thought back
into a six well so it's kind of like a
one-two-three split and and you'll kind
of have to figure that out on your own
like how good is your freezing method
and what what split ratio do you need to
freeze the cells and then softened and
thaw them back but I find that counting
isn't really necessary unless you're
doing something let's say you're going
to electro create the cells or do some
method where you do need to have an
exact cell number but in that case
you're gonna singular eyes the cells
anyways so you know that that's that's
that's when you would do a count going
back more into the passage in part of it
you mentioned that this is the reagent
of choice four essential eight medium
how about stem flex medium uh sure so
stem flex I mean is when you culture
cells and stem flex they're gonna you're
gonna kind of treat them very similarly
to how you would in in essential eight
similar matrices fit Renekton gel tracks
laminin and so you're passing method
would also EDTA would work just fine
there may be again you know subtle
differences in incubation times and
split ratios that you would use you know
going from essentially at stem flex it
might not be exactly the same between
the two media but but overall it's the
same basic method yeah there does seem
to be a difference in the kind of
methods that are used with different
media but in this case it is similar and
to that point one of our participants is
currently using collagenase for passing
their cells how does EDTA compared to
collagenase sure so so i mean if we were
culturing cells on on feeders on meth we
typically use collagenase that that
works the best I would not recommend
trying EVGA for cell's passages on
method
it's not going to end well I've tried it
and it doesn't work but conversely I
would not use collagenase for sales
culture and feeder freon essentially it
also just doesn't work very well so you
know ie DTA is going to give you the
best results for essentially and I would
say classiness would probably give you
better results for cells on on feeders
so then is there ever a situation where
you would use a different passage in
reagent with any DTA and what reagent
for what application sure so as I
mentioned earlier if there was if you
were using a protocol where you had to
take the cells and make them single
cells like I said let's say you're doing
a lecture a ssin or flow cytometry fax
sorting things like that where the cells
have to be single cells then you need to
use a different pathogen reagent for
regular passage you want to keep the
cells as clumps you're going to use EDTA
for cells into central later simplex but
when the cells need to be single cells
for a specific protocol I would
recommend using triple that's that's the
one we use the most it's pretty gentle
in the cells and it will give you good
results if you do have to make yourself
single cell somewhat related some of the
protocols on our website mentioned
versine there's a question on how that
is different from EDTA so first scene is
pretty much an EDTA solution it's just
already it's a ready-made solution so
the solution I'm using here is a point 5
millivolts I've molar I just diluted it
in PBS and sterile filtered it versine
is like a ready to use solution it's I
believe it's point four eight millimolar
you know pretty close and but but it's
just it's pre-made right you don't have
to dilute it it comes sterile ready to
use the one thing I would say is that it
should most EDTA solutions are just
shelf-stable you can leave them out on
the you know leave them out at room
temperature first scene is actually
recommended to be stored in in the deli
at you know two to 80 degrees so just
make sure you warm it up to room
temperature
or you use it if you are going to use a
verse scene if you add it cold that's
obviously going to change their
incubation times right and do you
recommend using revita cell or iraq
inhibitor during routine passages which
is better so I I don't think we tend to
avoid using Rock inhibitor unless we
need it so if you're if you're doing
regular passage with EDTA you should not
need to use either a Rock inhibitor or
revita cell but if you are as I said
doing those protocols where you need
your cells to be a single cell then then
you are going to need something like a
rock inhibitor or vitae cell you know
provide a cell is is easy to use I mean
if it comes you just add it to your
media you can use a rocket hitter
they'll probably have very similar
effects but I would say remind ourselves
a little bit easier to use since it's
ready to ready to go already sterile but
yeah I mean I would recommend only using
revita cell for your cultures when
you're plating the mass single cells you
leave it in there for 24 maybe 48 hours
after you play to them and then you move
on to to a media without without that in
there
there's a question here what happens if
the cells stay too long in EDTA
he's kind of covered but you can
reiterate sure you know I mean I've
actually I've experimented with this I
mean you could leave them in there for
probably half an hour at room
temperature and in most cases they
wouldn't they wouldn't necessarily start
floating on their own but you know when
you go to harvest them they'll just come
off like instantaneously and then I
think even if you're being very gentle
you'll end up with clumps that are
extremely small so I mean I don't think
it's gonna destroy your culture but it
will probably recover a lot slower and
you might have a longer period of time
between between cultures initially as
they as they kind of recover from being
you know clumps that are too small so we
just received a comment that vit
Renekton increases cell adherence or I
guess the question in general would be
would there be a difference in how in
the culture and Association protocols
were the different matrices sure that's
a good question
I think in general you're not gonna see
huge differences and I would I see more
differences between different cell lines
than I do between you know one cell line
on different matrices so you I mean keep
it in mind if you're going from veteran
actin and then you're and then all of a
sudden those cells are saying on gel
tracks and you're gonna harvest em it it
may take longer keep that in mind but in
general I don't see any huge differences
in incubation times with one cell line
on different matrices someone related
there is someone in the audience who has
seen some cells still sticking through
the plate after flushing how do they fix
that or is that really an issue good
question so it depends if if those cells
are not differentiated cells then yeah I
may mean that just next time you're you
should treat a little bit longer with
the EDTA you know maybe 30 seconds a
minute longer incubation time to try and
get them up but you know it may also be
that
BBJ will tend to preferentially lift up
pluripotent cells first and then and
then differentiated cells so you know
when you when you treat it for the right
amount of time it might actually leave
differentiated cells behind so I'm not
sure in this case what cells are being
left behind but but you can kind of use
this to to try and clean up their
cultures bye bye
you know releasing and removing the the
pluripotent stem cells first and kind of
leaving the differentiated cells behind
here's another good one one of our
participants is worried that they don't
flush the cells right it's a it's a bit
of a big question but I get what they're
asking to Chad how do you know what is
too strong or too weak in terms of the
flushing pressure and how many times is
there a specific number that you kind of
aim for sure yeah I mean this is one of
those things you kind of just have to
get a feel for with experience the more
you do it the more comfortable you'll
get I you know there's not a hard set
number of you know five times is perfect
and six times is too many
again you'll kind of just get a sense
for it as you as you as you do this you
know I mean and like I said I mean the
incubation time kind of dictates how
things are going to go if you think you
baited properly when you go to to lift
the cells up you shouldn't have to use
that much pressure and they should kind
of just gently come off so if you're not
seeing that I would try to increase your
incubation time next para yeah your ETA
incubation time the next time you try to
pass their cells and you know it's up
and down how many times is right I mean
just minimize it as much as possible
right and really it's just kind of you
have to just get a feel for it
and one last question after 4 minutes
and EDTA if the cells are not lifted do
we just eyeball the time increments can
we just eyeball the time increments sure
keep looking yeah I mean that's where I
was trying to say when you look at the
cells say they're still in the EDT and
you want to look at them and decide if
they're ready it's very hard to know
just by looking at them if they're ready
so I you know
you can you can certainly try to if
they're not coming off easily I would
say just next time yeah add 30 seconds
if they still don't come off easily add
30 seconds next time keep going like
that but but I yeah it's very hard to
look at him and say oh I need 30 small
seconds they don't look right I know
like when you're doing collagenase you
can kind of look at them and get a
better sense
ETT aids it's a little more it's a
little more subtle got it so thank you
Chad for your responses and thank you
all for your participation I hope this
has been a great learning experience if
we didn't get to your question we'll try
to address them afterwards by email or
you can ask our experts at their exhibit
hall or technical support chat boxes if
you need to see the demonstration again
this video will be available on demand
along with other trainings and
scientific talks for 24 hours of stem
cells please enjoy the rest of our event
today and continue to take advantage of
the resources even afterwards
[Applause]
you